[Musik]
corona versprechen gebrochen warnung vor
dem neuen selbstbestimmung gesetz und
industrie und handel täuschen die
verbraucher das sind unsere themen heute
aber damit herzlich willkommen bei
viertel nach acht meine gäste sind
allgemeinarzt und autor gunter frank
finne lauterbach lernt nicht dazu
professor und klinikdirektor für
kardiologie der berliner charité ist
sich hingegen sicher die pandemie ist
nicht vorbei corona greift die herzen an
ich bin gespannt sie besorgt sich
weniger um krone und mehrung des
selbstbestimmungsrechts wir selbst nahm
testosteron lässt sich die brüste
abnehmen und wollte einen mann sein
heute waren sie mit ihrem eigenen
schicksal vorzustellen
geschlechtsumwandlung was ich ganz mutig
findet schön dass sie heute abend hier
sind last but not least stefan schritte
auch er war nicht vor
geschlechtsumwandlung sondern von
technischen geräten die so gebaut werden
dass sie nach einer gewissen zeit
automatisch den geist aufgeben wir
werden also etwas lernen schön dass sie
alle da sind mein name ist nina schenk
um mein thema heute abend ist es
gebrochene corona versprechen vielleicht
erinnern sie sich noch wie ich am 20
märz 2022 versprach justizminister marco
buschmann das ende der krone lassen sie
uns mal reinhören
es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
wir wissen ja alle dass dieses
versprechen jetzt nicht so ganz
eingehalten wurde ich würde sogar sagen
gebrochen manche maßnahmen wie die
massen pflicht im zug oder im flugzeug
dagegen ist übrigens die lufthansa heute
sehr dagegen getreten ja die hatten wir
immer auch im sommer wurde nichts
abgeschafft und jetzt gelten ja auch
neue maßnahmen welche sich je nach lage
entwicklung sogar noch verschärfen
können obendrein muss man dazu sagen
dass marco buschmann dieses versprechen
ja niemals hätte geben müssen deswegen
auch meine erste frage an herr frank
buschmann warum hat er dieses
versprechen jetzt gegeben und dann
wieder gebrochen also musste erst
brechen aufgrund der gesundheitlichen
lage steht uns wieder ein killervirus
zuvor wie ist die lage in deutschland
also ich sage ihnen mal das was die
lungen erste sagen sowohl die chefs des
verbandes der jungen kliniken alles noch
nie dass dem jungen ärzte es gibt quasi
seit früher keine echten quelle mehr es
gibt keine
typischen kurvig lungenentzündung mehr
die diese erkrankung ist in schon langem
endemischen zustand mir hat letzte woche
einen lungenfacharzt geschrieben aus
niedersachsen einzugsgebiet
hunderttausend patienten alles geht über
ihn in die krankenhäuser noch die
nachsorge sagt zeit früher hat er keiner
kurvig lungenentzündung da gesehen also
ich weiß nicht was die da in berlin
veranstalten aber kubik 19 ist in den
kliniken nach meinung der lungenärzte
nicht mehr existent also sie würden
jetzt sagen marco buschmann handy sein
versprechen rück halten können
gesundheitlich gesehen ja ich setze ich
sag noch mal genau was ich davon halte
ich kann es schon mal voraus nehmen also
das ist unsäglich ich weiß nicht was
diese panikmacher noch soll kann man
nach einem anriss diskutieren was der
vielleicht dahinter steckt aber hier
wird komplett übertrieben und während am
anfang wie 19 wirklich auch zu schweren
lungen unserem geführt hat bei weitem
ich in dem ausmaß ja immer gesagt wurde
auch das war definitiv der fall gibt es
diese erkrankung laut lungenärzte das
sagte thomas voss der präsident der
jungen ärzte der kliniken auch
öffentlich gibt es de facto eigentlich
nicht mehr
wieder also ich sehe es ein wenig anders
wie nicht anders zu erwarten also
die schweren verläufe die sehen wir
tatsächlich weniger also an der charité
liegenden moment 100 patienten stationär
ein viertel davon ist intensiv pflicht
ich dass es deutlich weniger als das
haben doch die haben die haben zum teil
auch jungen sie ist zum teil will ja
also es ist ein kleinerer anteil wie
viel gerade die auf den
intensivstationen liegen was mir ganz
wichtig ist der prozentuale anteil der
wäre ganz spannend also wie viel prozent
corona patienten liegen gerade in der
charité auf der intensivstation
es sind etwa 20 bis 25 prozent
derjenigen die stationär aufgenommen
stoppte haben einen positiven test die
sind nicht groß und carina cupid
patienten ja also das sind cupid
patienten was wir vermehrt sehen sind
patienten die wegen anderen erkrankungen
aufgenommen werden und dann auch noch
sich herausstellt dass sie hiv-positiv
sind das heißt wir können nicht sagen
dass die 20 patienten wegen krone auf
der insel sind und denjenigen die wegen
kurve erkrankungen jetzt auf der
intensivstation sind das ist deutlich
weniger wir haben keine sag ich mal
überlastungen der intensivstation mir
wuchs man sich prozent wegen kubik
lungenentzündung auf intensiv der die
geringe deutlich geringeren anzahl von
patienten die wir wegen kurve jetzt
stationär aufnehmen müssen also
gegenüber sagen wir mal vor einem jahr
oder dem winter ist das deutlich weniger
also die ressourcen durch primär co wird
erkrankte im gesundheitswesen werden
nicht mehr so belastet wir hatten das ja
einmalig belastet was ist das in
absoluten bezahlen damit man als bürger
mal ein einblick also wie viele absolute
zahlen also wie viele liegen jetzt im
krankenhaus cupid 19 also ich kann sagen
in der charité sind es derzeit etwa 100
und von vielen
mit einem positiven test ist ein großer
unterschied es sind patienten die
entweder wegen primär einer cupid
infektion in die klinik gekommen sind
oder aber auch wegen einer anderen
erkrankung jetzt mit einem schweren ko
witt verlaufen aber herr professor
pieske damit kann man doch nicht
arbeiten wir müssen doch wissen wie
viele patienten exakt wegen kurve dem
krankenhaus den wir wissen wir dass dies
die die wii nicht in der lage ist dann
auch die krankenhausgesellschaft immer
noch nicht sauber zu unterscheiden haben
wir echte kurven fehler oder nur
positive test so kann man kein paar
nehmen die management machen ja und wenn
wir die lungenärzte sagen sie sehen
keine cupid lungenentzündungen dann ist
die pandemie vorbei und zwar seit früher
und da möchte ich auch noch mal die
anfrage von herrn kubicki erinnern also
in das gesundheitsministerium er hat
gefragt wie kann es sein dass er in vier
wochen im mai
die täglichen berichte des aks von
insgesamt 1800 covi toten sprachen und
im bericht monatsbericht zum gleichen
zeit haben nur von 98 toten gesprochen
wurde das ist das faktor 20 die antwort
war gewesen weil in dieser statistik
flossen und die ein- und wo man eben im
status kannte und die auch symptom
hatten ich bitte sie der impfstatus ist
bekannt die in den altenheimen wird
gehen die teams durch die dokumentieren
dass das heißt die meisten dieser kurve
toten hatten überhaupt keine kowitz
symptome also in tschuldigung ich habe
immer ein medizinstudium was anderes
gelernt eine krankheit ist er an einer
krankheit nicht wenn ich sie einfach nur
so ein händler sondern wenn die symptome
da sind so können wir nicht weitermachen
also ich möchte eigentlich das augenmerk
und das ist auch ein thema für das ich
jetzt eingeladen worden bin auf ein
anderes problem denken nämlich longo er
kann begleichen das weiß ich aber aber
wenn wir über sage ich mal die belastung
in unserer gesellschaft durch eine
erkrankung sprechen dann muss man auf
der einen seite natürlich sehen wie die
akute gefährdung der patienten ist und
auf der anderen seite was dann die
langzeit- und ich bin ganz froh dass wir
darüber gleich reden werden aber was wir
jetzt gerade machen wollen ist die
politik hat immer gesagt die maßnahmen
sind gerechtfertigt wegen der
überlastung der intensivbetten wegen der
möglichen überlastung der krankenhäuser
dann sie ja ganz klar gesagt das haben
wir im moment nicht eine überlastung
eine überlastung moment nicht genau
deswegen ist natürlich die frage an die
runde ich mache jetzt auch mal gerne auf
nachdem ich ihnen beiden das doppel
gelassen habe ob man wie sehen sie das
denn als bürger also die überlastung
haben bin ich da sind sich die beiden ja
einig die gibt es aktuell nicht warum
also noch die maßnahmen der politik also
erstmals bürger fragen will ich erst mal
sagen ich finde solche zahlen schlachten
sehr unangenehm ja also wenn sie werfen
zahlen im raum sie müssen jetzt auch
zahlen reagieren das ist wie eine art zu
diskutieren also ich bin vater von zwei
kindern ich bin selber co wieder krank
gewesen wenn ich gerne nicht gewesen
hätte ich die emotionale basis
linkenheim nicht die emotionale basis
sondern nehmen wir mal ein ding als
profit aufkam war es ein lohnproblem mit
intensiv belastung wenn er das heute
nicht mehr haben dann würde ich sagen
dann ist das ja nicht notwendigerweise
der grund dafür dass man heute trotzdem
mit maßnahmen reagieren will weil heute
gibt es so themen sie sprechen es ja an
longo wie heute gibt es vielleicht gibt
es ja
durch die neuen viren andere
erkrankungen andere situationen deswegen
dann vorsichtsmaßnahmen notwendig sind
also wir möchten dass die sie finden es
gut dass die politik weiter die
maßnahmen hat wie beispielsweise masken
pflicht im flieger heute lufthansa
selber das unternehmen gesagt hat sie
wollen das nicht mehr haben um eine
maßnahme jetzt wird erst mal sagen was
der das flugunternehmen selber gerne
hätte oder nicht hätte kann nicht
relevant sein für die frage wie man
schutzmaßnahmen zum wohl der bevölkerung
politik weiß alles bei wahrnehmen würde
ich so nicht sagen also flieger finde
ich zum beispiel interessantes thema ich
bin selber ja auch geflogen und die
flieger haben ja gute hepa filter drin
und das heißt im flugzeug unterwegs ist
das eigentlich sehr gut geschützt
dadurch weil die luft durch die
zirkulation sehr gut gerade warum nach
den meisten fehlt beispielsweise ein
pfleger gute frage wodurch fragen würde
ich auch sagen ich verstehe ich jetzt
nicht kann man doch eigentlich erklären
ich meine ja irgendwo in den büros
überall werden gerade diese mobilen hepa
filter aufgestellt dann wird gesagt ihr
könnt jetzt im büro zusammen ohne maske
sitzen weil ihr habt euch da jetzt und
lüfter hingestellt mit hepa filter drin
ja ob ein flieger soll es dann nicht
klappen da verstehe ich dann noch dass
manche sagen nee das will ich jetzt
nicht zusammen mit der ampel politik
nicht ganz ich würde eher sagen liebe
leute wir haben doch jetzt was also ich
suche eigentlich den lernerfolg den
versuche ich jetzt eigentlich zu
verstehen wir haben jetzt ja eine zeit
lang wie gehabt wir haben eine pandemie
gehabt wir haben viele
vorsichtsmaßnahmen gehabt jetzt mit
sicherheit haben die ganze menge leute
studien darüber angefertigt was heraus
gekriegt wie könnte man das besser
machen und wenn dann das maßnahmenpaket
so den geschmack hat na ja wir machen
das noch mal so wie vorher dann frage
ich mich als bürger er ich hätte jetzt
gerne kommunikation zum lernerfolg also
dass man gemerkt hat was man so richtig
gut gebracht hat das was und überhaupt
nichts gebracht hat das was aber wir
müssen hier gab es ja aber wir fragen
einmal frau blank wie sehen sie das denn
als bürgerin mit dem koma versprechen
was gebrochen wurde also ich würde sagen
jetzt im sommer sich die masken ehrlich
gesagt nicht sonderlich effizient weil
deshalb derzeit einfach die zahlen nicht
hergeben aber wenn es im winter jetzt
oder märz wieder in größeren ausbruch
sieht dann kann ich schon verstehen dass
man irgendwie haben möchte was man im
öffentlichen nahverkehr und im flugzeug
und zum beispiel deutsche bahn eben die
masse trägt damit zum beispiel hier ist
nicht zum notstand kommt in bestimmten
berufssparten dass es zum beispiel zu
wenige krankenpfleger einem bestimmten
bereich gibt also da sehe ich dann
wirklich als wichtig an aber dann würde
ich dann war wirklich reagieren wenn
irgendwie die zahlen hochschnellen und
nicht einfach generell sagen dass man
immer diese masken tragen sie haben sie
persönlich angst vor einem schweren
verlauf sie sind ja unter 30 haben sie
selber angst nee ich persönlich habe
ehrlich gesagt keine angst ich habe ich
als kind eine lungenentzündung und
eigentlich dann zu dieser risikoklasse
aber also ich hab da selber eine kurve
erkrankung im februar und ich hatte ja
eine mandelentzündung kein husten dabei
deshalb mit mandeln zu einem komme ich
gut klar hätte ich jetzt wussten wer ist
eine andere sache
es gehe darum wird sie machen vielleicht
darf ich ganz gut etwas was vom blanken
angesprungen hat eingehen dass ich mich
ein ganz wichtiger punkt
personalausfälle also das ist bei uns
schon ein thema und wir haben im moment
krankheitsbedingt personalausfälle in
der klinik an der charité zwischen fünf
und zehn prozent das unterschreitet
unterschiedliche berufsgruppen und ein
guter teil davon ist kurve die viele
dürfen nicht mehr arbeiten wegen der
einrichtungs beziehungen pflicht bei
ihnen wenn wir über den pflegenotstand
sprechen das spielt keine rolle weil die
fast alle gegen da gibt es welche die
bei ihnen nicht genehmigt sind
minimalste unter die der frau nicht mehr
arbeiten richtig die sind eigentlich von
den am patienten an alle arbeit am
patienten nicht mehr zugelassen aber wie
gesagt bei uns bilden das keine rolle
eine rolle spielt es für sie keine rolle
wenn sie darüber sprechen dass pfleger
man sie braucht und sie sagen ja sagen
die haben die sozialen 1 gefehlt das
keine rolle was wirklich eine rolle
spielt ist eben der der ausfall durch
kurven erkrankung das merken wir dass
ich das ist dann eine rolle wenn man
jetzt schon von gebrochenen versprechen
sprechen ist das nicht seltsam dass wir
ihnen alle geimpft sind und so viele
kurve bekommen ausfallen was sagt uns
das denn die impfung schützt nicht davor
und da kommt auch noch mal richtig da
jedoch entschieden dass es vielleicht
vor dem schweren verlauf aber nicht
komplett davor setzen sie sich
darstellen doch so kann ich darstellen
und wir kamen gleich noch überleben wir
müssen darüber
noch mal sprechen aber weil die zahlen
sind wichtig selbst der bruder von herrn
scholz ja als klinikdirektor sagt es ist
ein wahnsinn jemand wegen einen
positiven test nach hause zu schicken
obwohl er gesund ist oder vielleicht
auch die quarantäne regeln sollte sich
diese personalprobleme entstehen nicht
durch cupid 19 sondern mit dem umgang
damit ist ein großer unterschied also
das ist ein völliges märchen das kogit
19 zu personalengpässen führt durch das
virus selbst es ist der umgang damit er
in der für frank der keine symptome
zeigen kann wie auch früher arbeiten ich
bin dafür dass man diesen test
verwendet so für das was er gemacht ist
wenn ich an der differentialdiagnose
brauche bei symptomen bei schwerkranken
menschen ob derjenigen vielleicht sonst
oft 2 erkrankt ist dann ist dieser test
sinnvoll diesen test an symptomen losen
menschen einzusetzen ist kompletter
humbug das ist international so klar
wird dass gesehen aber wir deutschen
machen einfach immer weiter
weg also ich weiß nicht ob das ein
sonderweg ist ich möchte noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass wir natürlich in der
klinik umgehen mit hochrisiko menschen
gekommen weil sie schwer krank sind und
wenn wir die jetzt auch noch in der
klinik anstecken und wir haben ja solche
situationen auch wir sehen das ja dann
bringen wir die in eine ganz besondere
gefahrenlage deswegen glaube ich schon
dass es gerechtfertigt ist dass man hier
ein besonderes augenmerk darauf legt
dass die patientinnen und patienten die
sich in behandlung begeben
so gut es geht da vorgeschlagen werden
masken getragen rich und wasserläufe
ebenfalls angesagt die anderen dürfen
hier nicht mehr zählen und dann haben
sie so einen hohen krankheitsstand was
bringen die maßnahmen denn dann also
noch einmal
das wollte ich eigentlich immer noch mal
an der hörn kollegen frank sagen die
impfung hat uns wahnsinnig weiter
gebracht weil sie und das haben wir
gerade mit dem intensiv zahlen ja auch
gesehen weil sie eben die schweren
krankheitsverläufe
massiv reduzierter andere sagen dass der
im test die dass der virus einfach
leichter wurde und mutiert ist und
dementsprechend auch weniger als 1
standen also ich will das nicht
kommentieren was andere sagen sondern
ich will kommentieren was die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse über die
ergebnisse der impfungen sagen und die
impfung und das haben sie ganz richtig
gesagt reduziert das risiko auch an
kurve zu erkranken aber er schließt eine
kurve infektion nicht aus das muss man
auch mal ganz klar sagen so dass es
möglich ist dass ich heute trotz
dreifacher impfung eine kurve die
infektion bekommen positiv werde
vielleicht minimale symptome habe und
das ist ja glaube ich auch er ihr
argument oder auch ein bisschen mehr
symptome habe symptome wie bei einem
grippalen infekt aber ich bin während
diesem zeitpunkt infektiös für andere
das muss man ganz klar sagen und wenn
ich jemand anstecke der ein hochrisiko
patienten oder mensch ist dann bringe
ich den vielleicht in groß ist so
schließen sowie sowieso schließen sie
den usa schließen sie dann um gangster
aus wenn die geimpften mit cupid
symptomen dann ein problem für die
kranken sende ich verstehe das nicht ich
verstehe diese logik nicht
noch mal was meint sie haben gerade gilt
von geimpften mitarbeitern gesprochen
die wenn sie einen positiven test haben
wir dann eine gefahr sind für die
kranken ja wie das ist doch das argument
dass sie die ungeimpften ausschließen
die ungeimpften sie noch eine gefahr für
die kranken gezogen sie die geimpften
sind eine gefahr für die kranken also
irgendwie ist das alles also ich finde
es nicht richtig gas also erfand und
natürlich sollte komplett durcheinander
ist da gar nicht herr frank man
wahrscheinlich dass man sich ja auch bei
der impfung anstecken kann und auch
patienten anstecken kann wenn man kämpft
weiter wir haben eine einigung zur gerät
wir haben eine einrichtung gezogene
impfpflicht dort verlieren eben 60
jährige altenpflegerin ihren job die
werden rausgeschmissen wenn sie einfach
aus gutem grund sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen weil sie angeblich eine gefahr
für die kranken sind und gerade haben
sie gesagt die geimpften sind an eine
gefahr für die kranken deswegen muss ich
sie testen also das ist das kann ich
nachvollziehen also ich kann es gut
nachvollziehen es können auch viele
menschen gut nachvollziehen wenn die die
impfung schützt nicht vor der erkrankung
wenn ich erkrankt bin in der akutphase
bin ich hoch infektiös kann andere
anstecken das ist das entscheidende
kriterium das ein infektiöser mensch
nicht an einen anderen hochinfektiösen
anderen menschen hochrisiko anderen
menschen also patienten in unserem
kontext heran gehen darf und sie müssen
sich ja vorstellen die pflegekräfte aber
auch die ärzte und so weiter wir
arbeiten ja zum teil ganz nah am
patienten ich glaube dass weiter um geld
eigentlich immer wieder neue gesetz
these sie sind ich glaube wir gehen
jetzt einmal weiter nochmal zu den
tieren sind ja nicht mediziner oder wenn
sie sagen dass da wenn so nicht sage
nichts
sagen ich finde es unverantwortlich aus
arbeitgebers ich bin selber arbeitgeber
gewesen man darf die arbeit
schutzinteressen das individuellen
mitarbeiters nicht einfach so schlicht
außen macht außer acht lasse das
passiert ja bei der einrichtung
situation eine fläche einfach mal
krankenhäuser raus ich bin jetzt mal
ganz normaler arbeitgeber ich habe
irgendwie meint wegen der firma und der
arbeitende 200 mitarbeiter drin jetzt
kann ich nicht alle dazu bringen zu
sagen legt man euren gesundheitsstatus
offen welche habt ihr irgendwelche
schwierigen risiko erkrankungen weil das
feld alles unter daten denke so des
staates bewusste offengelegt werden bei
den einkommen ist verschieden ich gerade
also wenn jetzt zb ich habe diabetes ich
hab's orie asus das sage ich so bin ich
jetzt bei einem arbeitgeber wäre und die
wäre der arbeitnehmer dann hätte ich ein
recht darauf dass für mich zu behalten
ich habe aber als mitarbeiter in einer
firma hat ein recht darauf dass mein
dass der vorgesetzte sorge trägt dafür
dass ich nicht an meinem arbeitsplatz
einem ja ich sag mal erkrankungsrisiko
ausgesetzt bin dass der arbeitgeber eine
arbeitsschutz pflicht wir machen jetzt
ein ganz neues thema auf das würde ich
jetzt gerne verschiedene spät ja es ist
nicht ganz neu sondern man kann nicht
alle auch so sagen nach dem motto man
sollte leute einfach überall rum laufen
lassen ohne maske ohne alles wenn sie
jemand anders anstecken können wir da
müssen wir fragen wie kann man das
sicher stellen dass man weiß ob jemand
ansteckungsfähigkeit also ob er eine ob
er den virus in sich trainer wenig
weil jeder ja heute seine these
mitgebracht wir wollen natürlich auch
die these von handys gehören und die ist
nämlich longo holt heute abend longo
wird ist jetzt sagen wir mal dass die
konsequenz aus dem was er jetzt
besprochen haben und
und tatsächlich ist longo wird etwas was
was mich ein bisschen besorgt macht und
zwar deswegen weil ich diese menschen
auch als kardiologe see und in der
funktion bin ich ja heute prima mal hier
die kommen nämlich weil sie symptome
haben und beschwerden die ganz ähnlich
sind wie menschen mit einer
herzmuskelschwäche so die patienten die
nach einer akuten kurve 19 infektionen
chinesen sind insofern dass der pcr test
negativ ist dass die akute infektion
abgeklungen ist häufig geht es den
kurzen bisserl besser und dann geht es
wieder schlechter oder es geht ihm gar
nicht mehr so wichtig besser und es geht
ihnen immer schlechter über wochen und
monate und daher kommt der begriff auch
longo witt die werden nicht mehr richtig
gesund über einen längeren zeitraum und
die symptome die die menschen berichten
und es waren vorher das sind häufig
junge menschen die ich sehe sind in
unserem umfeld auch mitarbeitende der
charité ärztinnen ärzte pflegekräfte
andere das sind 25 jährige 30-jährige
sportliche menschen die können nicht
mehr die haben eine erhebliche
körperliche leistungsschwäche sie haben
eine rasche ermüdbarkeit sie haben
kurzatmigkeit bei geringer belastung sie
können dinge des täglichen lebens nicht
mehr verrichten sie haben
konzentrationsschwäche
konzentrationsstörungen schlafstörungen
herzrhythmusstörungen und
die geraten tatsächlich in eine
verzweifelte lage und das ist etwas was
nicht ganz selten ist ich habe mir dazu
jetzt machen die zahlen nochmal
ausgesucht also wenn man jetzt auch
größere internationale untersuchungen
anschaut dann kriegen etwa zehn prozent
der kurve erkrankten dieses lankowitz
syndrom mit den symptomen die ich gerade
geschildert habe keine
leistungsfähigkeit schlappheit rasche
ermüdbarkeit kurzatmigkeit um eine frage
ja den haarausfall habe ich auch gelesen
es auch noch ein symptom von long kurve
sogar häufigsten studien aber eine sache
die deutsche gesellschaft für
pneumologie
und beatmungsmedizin sagt dass die
häufigkeit von longkou wird sehr schwer
zu erfassen
woher können sie dann also definitiv
sagen das ist durch corona kommt weil
zum beispiel die gesellschaft sagt es
ist sehr schwer zu erfassen ob es jetzt
wirklich diese zehn prozent sind bei dir
der zusammenhang schwer zu erfassen ist
korrekt der zusammenhang ist schwer zu
erfassen und natürlich sind diese ganzen
symptome auch ein wenig unspezifisch so
und dann kommt nämlich der teil 2 warum
kommen denn diese menschen zum
kardiologen ich sag mal wir haben zum
beispiel an der charité ein qubit 19 und
longo wird netzwerk da sind absolut die
experten da da gibt es zum beispiel
unser könig fertig center das ist ja
dann in der weiteren entwicklung des
chronische fatigue syndrom mit der von
professor die das schreiben drogen die
das leitet wo das sicher dass die zehn
prozent also die des liedes leitet die
diese menschen sehen diese zehn prozent
sind literaturangaben ich persönlich bin
da nicht sicher ob das acht oder 14
prozent sind aber es ist ein relevanter
anteil an menschen jetzt sage ich ihnen
mal meine erfahrung also ich sehe zum
beispiel menschen die sind sportler
gewesen und jetzt sind sie zwei drei
monate nach ihrer cupid infektion
arbeitsunfähig und es gibt auch einige
nach einer impfung waren ist das ist
dass 2020 anders gewesen wie jetzt ich
bin nicht sicher ob es anders gewesen
ist vielleicht gucken wir jetzt genauer
hin erkennen dass erich als kardiologe
kann nur sagen ich kenne diese
situationen aus der vergangenheit bei
jungen menschen die eine virale
myokarditis hatten
da gab es ganz gelegentlich genau solche
situationen und diese menschen sind von
pontius zu pilatus gerannt also ich kann
das auch im privaten kreis ich habe also
ich wollte noch mal zurück was ich
vorhin sagte weil sie machen eigentlich
deutlich dass es ein feld in dem
geforscht werden muss das untersucht
werden die aussagen die sie ja bewusst
schwach formulieren liege ja nicht daran
weil sie das nicht sagen können sondern
weil die datenlage fehlt die datenlage
fehlt aber deswegen weil nicht erhoben
wird es wirklich untersucht also nach
meinen diese schwer bewachten also ich
habe mich damit dass wir uns einmal und
expertenmeinungen denn genauso wie ihr
pc ist ja auch eher frank arzt wie
schätzen sie das denn ein mit longo wird
eine frage noch unterscheiden sie bei
den jetzigen patienten mit nach
virusinfektionen cupid und einer
kaffeemühle pathetisch in dem stall um
gangster patienten erfassen sie das
statistisch also die zahlen die die wir
jetzt sehen noch
gegeben dass noch nicht her um das so
erfassen das habe ich befürchtet er
professor pieske ich bezweifle ich mit
keinem moment dass sie eine vorwagen der
kardiologe sind und ihre patienten bei
ihnen auf station hervorragend behandelt
werden ich möchte sich dennoch massiv
kritisieren für das was ich gerade
gesagt haben erstens dass bürokratie das
problem ist ein problem der impfung bei
jungen männern das steht sogar der
neuesten publikation sekunden
circulation das kennen sie
wahrscheinlich da steht das explizit
drin es ist die impfung die die jungen
männer
bedroht kardiomyopathie des zweitens
wir haben keine auffällige sterblichkeit
in den corona jahren 2020 bis mitte 21
fakten gut mit reizen zahlen müssen sein
wir haben eine auffällige sterblichkeit
der 30 bis 75 jährigen ab mitte 21 als
die impfkampagne angefangen habe ich
sage nicht dass das die impfung ist also
das sind wirklich seriöse schätzungen
der 6000 menschen zusätzlich gestorben
sind die sonst nicht gestorben werden
dann es wird nicht dann haben sie gibt
diese studien wo sie sehen an muskeln
biopsie am herzmuskel dass die impfung
dort eine autoimmun geschehen auslöst so
und jetzt haben wir die gefährdung durch
die impfung was sie ihr gebiet angeht
und wir haben eine kurve erkrankung
geben lassen und jetzt bitte ausreden
ein schritt geht nicht sehen können
jetzt nicht einfach sagen wir hören ich
ungefähr so können wir sagte sie können
jetzt bitte nicht einfach mich so
unterbrechen ich darf das jetzt sagen
ist das wirklich sehr sehr sehr fachlich
sehr wichtig ja also sie haben die
gefährdung durch die impfung und sie
haben die gefährdung in seltenen fällen
durch coop 19 das zusammenaddiert bringt
jetzt durchaus das problem was sie sehen
aber ich möchte endlich eine publikation
sehen die das problem was sie schildern
bitte trend in geimpfte mit
kardiomyopathie viral und umkämpfte und
jetzt longo wird es gibt genügend
untersuchungen die zeigen dass diese
typischen symptome die heute alle da
rein vermengt werden ja
konzentrationsstörungen müdigkeit und
dergleichen genauso bei patienten
aufgetreten sind die nicht kopiert
hatten ich finde wir reden ja über long
lockdown maske es gibt die echten longo
wird patienten die meistens mit dem
chronic fatigue syndrom einher gehen die
gibt es bei krippe die gibt es für
epstein-barr-virus und diese patienten
haben leider von der medizin nicht viel
zu erwarten das ist leider so wir haben
noch nicht wirklich therapien für diese
patienten aber wir tun diesen patienten
keinen gefallen wenn wir ausland ein
riesenthema machen was es nicht ist es
ist für die meisten beschwerden die dann
mit eingerechnet werden ist es laut
lockdown maske und die kajomi partien da
hätte ich gern meine sauber untersuchung
die unterscheidet geimpft nicht geimpft
ich fürchte dass wir erleben dass
der park ist ja nicht einmal
unterbrechen darf
longo wird oder aufgrund der impfung
weil ich natürlich das thema
impfnebenwirkungen sehr ernst nehme
kommen natürlich selektiv besonders
viele patienten mit impfnebenwirkungen
das ist so die patienten mit ich hab
zwei vielleicht drei fälle oder ein fall
wo man sagen kann was durch die impfung
auch aufgetreten als ich erzähle man
fall fand jetzt der woche und ich habe
täglich solche fälle des besonders
eindrücklich ein junger mann 17 jahre
aus wie heißt das land habe
aufgeschrieben
ja also früher burma da gibt es
programme
die quasi eltern überreden ihre kinder
nach deutschland zu schicken für eine
schul stipendium und diese mutter hat
eingewilligt der junge mann kam nach
heidelberg hat den schul stipendium
bekommen und hat dort drei kurven die
impfung bekommen weil er als anteil
haben wollte am leben mit seinen
mitschülern seit vier monaten kann der
seine beine nicht mehr belasten und das
ist typisch ich habe bestimmt 30
patienten gesehen die genau diese
symptome nach der impfung hatten es ist
ein neuer muskuläres problem dass es
bekannt es gibt die zwischen 100 von
publikationen die das beschreiben und
dieser junge mann kann kein sport mehr
machen kann nicht mehr tanzen kann
nichts und jetzt kommt weder die schule
erkennt das an dass das mit dem vom
zusammenhängt noch die kollegen die
lassen denen alleine im regen stehen und
wissen sie was seine mutter in neumarkt
in dem bürgerkriegsgebiet bereut es
bitterlich dass sie ihren sohn in das
reiche deutschland geschickt hat wo er
geschädigt wurde obwohl das einfach
ignoriert wird und das finde ich ein
armutszeugnis für deutschland wir können
nicht mehr so mit dem schäden durch
gehen ich meine jetzt sind was mit
meinem thema schon gelandet ja aber sie
kann direkt weiter warum also jetzt
entschieden zimmer sie haben angefangen
haben eine wissenschaftliche arbeit aus
england zitieren und der haben komplett
falsch zitiert komplett falsch zitiert
sie haben genau das gegenteil gesagt von
dem was da drin steht ein harter vorwurf
ja da steht nämlich darin dass es nach
impfungen auch zu einer kardialen mit
beteiligung oder meo kredites autoimmun
vermittelt kommen kann das aber die
häufigkeit
nach der impfung viel seltener ist als
die häufigkeit wenn ich an cupid
erkranke und die kogit impfung schützt
mich genau vor dieser komplikation aber
es kann auch durch die heimauftritte er
sich irgendwann stehen nein ich habe sie
haben es wirklich falsch gelesen es
steht eindeutig drin ja dass man nicht
unterschieden hat man hat zwar
unterschieden bei geimpften und
ungeimpften aber man hat mich bei der
auswertung unterschiedene ungeimpfte
ungeimpft man hat nur die geimpften und
dem york athen verglichen mit den
lukrativen
nach kuwait aber man hat nicht
unterschieden ob dieser geimpft oder
ungeimpft waren unter schlusssatz der
conclusio circulation wir reden über
diesen artikel unter schluss hat bitte
lesen sie ihn nach den artikeln dasteht
glasklar drin das größte risiko für die
für die jungen männer ist die zweite
impfung und nicht 19 steht wortwörtlich
drin also bitte werfen sie mir nicht vor
dass ich die stute ich kann lesen also
ich finde dass ich kann mit so was
schlecht schlecht also erstens überhaupt
die ganze zeit kausalitäten ohne eigene
studien sie sind eine studie zitierte
was hast du da gibt es offensichtlich
nach sie beschreiben verliert diese
indira zeugen gesagt und stellen eine
kausalität her wo sie sagen die impfung
ist schuld daran dass das passiert das
behaupten sie haben nicht einen einzigen
beleg bisher dafür genannt und das
finden schwierig bin also was könnte ich
jetzt beispielsweise auch fälle eine
charité beschrieben mit
länger gesehen das ist ja das was sie
für etwas ich persönlich auch für
dringend notwendig halte ist das sind
wichtige aussagen die müssen untersuchte
eben sie werden aber gibt untersucht
es wird aber nicht getan
lauterbach gesagt hat
bei geimpften ist es so dass man oft
schon symptome hat bevor man überhaupt
ansteckend ist war die impfung führt
dazu dass sozusagen der körper sehr
schnell reagiert noch wenig viruslast
und dann erst kommen die während unserer
stadt die viruslast wir sehen uns auch
einer der gründe weshalb war sie die für
die impfungen die panne begrenzen weil
sehr häufig sind die leute schon mit
symptomen unterwegs und lagen dann auch
zu hause noch bevor sie wirklich
ansteckend sind weil bei demjenigen der
geimpft ist die symptome oft beginnen
bevor die viruslast sehr hoch ist
da kommen sie auf temperatur habe ich
mir sagen na ja
es ist nur halt computer sind also woher
weiß er dass er fast bezieht er sich und
es ist ein schönes beispiel dass wir von
anfang an der krise ich sag das jetzt
mal klar ein deutlicher schritt von
dilettanten blendern und scharlatanen
informiert werden ja es geht es treten
leute medial auf dominieren die meinen
dominieren die politischen
entscheidungen die völlig fakten frei
völlig frei von qualifikationen da ihre
empfehlungen geben wenn alle sagen ich
meine damit zum beispiel in lauterbach
ich mein zb auch herr montgomery oder
herrhausen ja ich habe bin vernetzt mit
den champions leagues experten zu diesen
themen ja weil ich wissenschaftliche
symposien veranstaltet haben habe ich
ein wahnsinnig gutes netzwerk das sind
die führenden um ärzte drin das sind
ehemalige leiter von
universitätskliniken sander ist der herr
schrappe treten da ist daher anders
drehen das sind die top leute und die
kommen nicht zu wort und es ist völlig
verrückt wir leben an der wirklichkeit
vorbei und deswegen haben wir von anfang
an der korona krise nehmen wir in der
lüge über 1 das corona virus hat er das
potenzial die es gibt deutsche
gesundheitswesen zu überlasten
zahlen was schätzen sie denn wie viel
war denn die belegung gewesen der
krankenhäusern werde eine unterbelegung
von 16 prozent immer noch von der von
den unter belegten krankenhäusern waren
zwei prozent kuwait patienten und wir
wissen dass die ort meistens falsch
postiert waren ja wo ist denn da bitte
schon die bedrohung für das gesundheits-
und es ist ein völliger unsinn also
integrierte sind nicht das sind zahlen
ich habe im krankenhaus gearbeitet die
pflegekräfte sind abgezogen wir haben
massiv zu kämpfen gehabt mit diesen
schwersten sterben dass sie
widersprechen den zahlen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums auf
homepage ist die leipziger natürlich so
jemanden sondern doch auszuschließen
eine unmittelbare persönliche erfahrung
die uns jetzt zwei jahre begleitet hat
und jetzt endlich diese situation durch
die impfungen wir haben den griff
gekriegt hatte die war wichtig sind wie
war denn die belegung der charité also
ich finde ich im vergleich zu 8 sie
machen hier wieder panik und die masse
machen
ich beziehe mich hier auf die klaren
zahna leipzig analyse die von der
bundesregierung beauftragt worden ist
sind diese diese diese studie unter
steht eindeutig drin wir hatten
historische unterbelegung in den corona
jahren und davon zwei prozent patienten
entschulden die panini bereits in
england ja ist denn da bitteschön die
überbelastung die wir nie dagewesen ja
und dann die liebe nummer zwei
der test weist keine infektion nach der
test weist nach virus trümmer ja also
jemand ohne symptome ist nicht krank ist
aber ständig in den sequenzen
eingeflossen lüge nummer 23 die impfung
ist
sicher die impfung schützt schauen sie
doch mal den die zahlen an der
krankenkassen der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung wir haben dramatische
zunahme von diagnosen wir haben
dramatische zunahme von
impfnebenwirkungen das ist alles fakt
und diese impfung ist eben nicht eine
masern impfung oder eine grippeimpfung
sondern sich seine bedingte zulassung
und dann muss man einfach mal eine text
lesen die bedingten zulassung wie hoch
die idee der anspruch der interimsweise
überwachung ist und unschuld und winter
und deswegen
schritte was egal was passiert was ich
glaube ich als es ist ja wirklich sie
sind ja die sind ja der patient sie sind
ja derjenige der an das alles adressiert
wird aber sie müssen wirklich wissen es
ich muss es nicht nachweisen dass es
kausal ist nichtig seien die idee dieser
jährige der die seite die das verfrüht
zulässt muss nachweisen dass das nicht
kausal ist das ein unterschied und diese
studien die sie selber auch genannt
haben werden nicht gemacht an der
charité war ein forscher der hat
versucht seine schule zu machen die
charité hat ihn zurückgepfiffen wir
haben hier wirklich wir lassen die leute
ins offene messer laufen und diese
experten die ich als dilettanten
bezeichnung das war das nämlich auch
lauterbach dazu die haben oft knall
hatte interessenskonflikte ja wenn herr
montgomery zb hier ständig von der
katastrophe spricht
der ist wissenschaftlicher beirat einer
firma die mit aktien handelt genauso wie
herr chancen lauterbach hat in seiner
karriere schon sehr viele gefährliche
medikamente gefeatured die dann vom
markt genommen worden sind ja sehr
fragwürdig überhaupt sehr viel ist
sollte man fragwürdig aber weg ins
aber wir können so nicht weitermachen
wir müssen ehrlich die top leute holen
und die top epidemiologen die top
infektiologen und die top el sol
forscher die die 400 politik bestimmen
lassen die frauen das sagen was jetzt
auch durch gesetzen umgesetzt wurde also
herr frank in thüringen sind bitte ich
muss nochmal ganz klar sagen was sie
hier verbreiten das ist ich verstehe das
gar nicht ihre persönliche meinung ich
wollte dass gerade sagen propaganda das
wollte ich nicht kann ich sagen was ist
aber
lassen sie doch auch mal aus kanada
sie werden mit irgendwas verwandelt und
verbunden also ich keine ahnung also
davon weiß ich nichts und ich kenne
viele namhafte internationale
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
epidemiologen virologen infektiologen
die absolut diese haltung teilen dass
uns die impfung aus dieser krise zum
teil raus geführt hat die krise ist
nicht überwunden das muss man ganz klar
sagen die maske schützt uns wenn wir das
wollen wir brauchen selbstverständlich
eigenverantwortung jeder muss auch
schauen dass er für sich und für sein
umfeld das richtige tut und ich glaube
da ist die ganze gesellschaft auf ganz
ganz stark sensibilisiert aber die daten
und fakten die ich kenne die
entsprechend nicht in keinster weise dem
was sie hierfür klasse ist doch also ich
verstehe dass wegen hartz iv die sind
ihnen zahlen egal der krankenkassen sind
ihnen die über sterblichkeit egal die
mit der impfkampagne zusammen ist das in
alles egal wissen sie was was ich glaube
ich glaube dass sich die verantwortung
für diese parole politik irgendwann vor
gericht wegen fahrlässiger tötung zu
verantworten haben das wird kommen es
geht gar nicht anders weil diese opfer
die wir inzwischen schon haben ja die
die wirklichkeit die klopft nicht mehr
wirklich an die tür die dritte karte ein
und das ist absolut absolut nicht
hinnehmbar was ich ja sagen beim thema
corona werden wir nicht mehr auf einen
grünen zweig kommen aber das wollen wir
auch gar nicht streit ist er hier
erlaubt beginnen ganz kurz unterbrechen
gekommen damit zwei spannenden ganz
anderen themen zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter koch
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen die damen und herren
bei 14 85 köpfen und meinungen jeder von
uns hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn
bewegt freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht retuschiert
auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur derart zu überlassen lasst den
leuten noch mal einen spaß wir sehen ja
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten deren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig dürfte sein
einmal kurz einsatz also immer noch das
unmögliche andrack träger ausdruck
bringen ich habe meinen beifall über
eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
sich darum niemand
will denn da ist ja ganz klar ist
eigentlich auch darüber sprechen das ist
einfach nicht fertig richtig wo ist die
aufgabe von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wesen zurück und wir werden jetzt über
das selbstbestimmungsrecht sprechen ich
will gar nicht so viel vorweg nehmen
eine besonders mutige junge frau heute
hier sitzen habe und die soll direkt ihr
thema selbst erzählen
ich möchte damit starten wir so einfach
die tradition also ich hab selber eine
tradition gemacht das heißt dass man
sich als frau als mann fühlt und dann
der meinung ist dass es von selber
zukünftig besser ist das durchzuziehen
das ist einfach nicht für alle der
richtige weg ist also viele sind der
meinung sie müssen tradition ihren
danach ist alles super und es ist der
wunderwaffe das alles funktioniert und
danach irgendwie nach ein paar jahren
hormone oder nacht pubertäts blockern
usw stellen sie dann für sich selber
fest dass es die falsche entscheidung
war und viele trauen sich dann aber auch
nicht jeden eigenen fehler
zuzugeben oder sind dann weiterhin in
der ihrer trans rolle selber drinnen
weil sie einfach nicht irgendwie darüber
hinweg kommen
sozusagen also nicht zugeben wollen das
ist eben dass sie fehler gemacht haben
und
genau
ich finde dann selber in der messenger
gruppe drin wo es halt um die 20 die
transaktion ihre rinnen jetzt
tatsächlich schon gibt und wir probieren
uns immer über das thema auszutauschen
weil viele auch dass die fähigkeit haben
wenn sie haben mit den männlichen
hormonen zb aufhören dass ihn keine
weiblichen hormone mehr verschrieben
werden dass da dann plötzlich gutachten
gefordert werden die vorher nicht der
gefordert worden sind bei dem ersten weg
und
jetzt möchte ja die bundesregierung
neues gesetz machen das heißt dann dass
selbstbestimmung ist gesetz und bei
diesen selbstbestimmung das gesetz solle
jeder bürger einfach zum standesamt
hingehen kann und dort sein neues seinen
neuen geschlechts wunsch angeben können
das heißt dass frauen können plötzlich
rechtliche männer werden und aus männern
rechtliche frauen und es gibt ja ich
auch in claire beauftragten nun viele
aus der lgbt community haben
befürchtungen was dieses gesetz angeht
zum beispiel dass viele lesben viele
schwule viele bisexuelle
transaktion ihren könnten also genau in
diese rolle dann rein fallen könnten was
sie sich einfach als frauen zb untypisch
als käufer halten oder männer
die sich halt und typisch männlich also
eher weiblich verhalten und genau da
gibt es eigentlich viel widerspruch aber
der wehrbeauftragte wird leider diesen
leuten nicht zu da gibt es zb de das ist
romantik national international oder die
elg die alliance da gibt es auch in
deutschen abzweig davon oder latz
reloaded das ist das lesbische
aktionszentrum reloaded das waren die
alten lassen um aus den 70er jahren die
jetzt der meinung sind wieder ihren
verein zurück ergründen zu müssen damit
sie eben eine opposition zu diesem
setzte stunden gesetzt haben sich bei
sich selbst bei ihrer eigenen geschichte
das gefühl gehabt dass wenn man
vielleicht mehr aufgeklärt wäre oder
sogar mehr kontrollen stattgefunden mehr
gespräche noch sie ist vielleicht gar
nicht gemacht hätten zum beispiel sich
die brüste abzunehmen ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt das ist schwierig gewesen wäre
also tatsächlich bei der mastektomie da
hätte mir ja ich denke ich schon noch
davon abhalten können also ich hatte
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so ein
vorgespräch bei dem krankenhaus was ich
jetzt aber nachträglich leider nicht
mehr nachweisen kann aber ich hatte
damals für die krankenkassen was
unterschrieben darf sich dieses
vorgespräch hatte was halt nicht
stattgefunden hat
also wenn dann über die aufklärung
gewesen wäre dann hätte ich womöglich
die maxiq toni nicht gemacht aber ich
glaube von den hormonen hätte man mich
ehrlich gesagt nicht abbringen können
weil ich da einfach in dieser
transkripte damals drinnen war wo sehr
viele leute eben tradition irrt haben
die ich für mich als irgendwie als
vorbild gesehen habe also ja sehr
männlich auftretende frauen und ich habe
einfach ein vorbild gesucht weil ich ja
selber in bayern groß geworden bin war
alles sehr sehr konservativ ist und weil
sie frauen geliebt haben haben sie dann
gedacht sie müssen eigentlich zum mann
werden genau genau und ich hab halt
einfach diese vorbilder gesucht und wir
haben halt alle gerade transaktion irrt
und dadurch war es halt besonders
schwierig weil man sich als vorbilder
wie man 20 jahren vielleicht sein könnte
und die nehmen aber gerade alles schon
testosteron und haben ihre mastektomie
und man erzählt sich das hat auch jede
woche wo die dann gerade auf jedem
traditions- weg gerade neu angekommen
sind und ja das animiert einen natürlich
auch diesen weg zu gehen obwohl es einem
selber womöglich gar nicht weiterhilft
dann kriegen ja jetzt auch harsche
kritik wenn sie ihre geschichte erzählen
habe ich mitbekommen
auch im netz warum
ja das ist eine gute frage also ich
glaube eigentlich einmal dieses negativ
hinterfragt das halt diese transaktion
einem halt irgendwie die glückseligkeit
sozusagen bringt also es ist fast schon
wieder so eine neue art von religion und
man darf das ganze halt nicht
hinterfragen also wenn man einfach schon
sagt dass biologie real ist also dass es
biologisch nur zwei geschlechter gibt
dann wird man halt runter gemacht wie
man an der biologin in berlin jetzt
sehen konnte
deren vortrag erstmal gecancelt wurde
und sie continental dann nachträglich
noch mal nachholen also es gibt einfach
dieses diese trennung im englischen also
ist es ja 6 und gender die gibt's halt
in deutschland nicht so wirklich weil
alle halt immer nur vom geschlecht reden
und es ist ja selbst im englischen
schwierig diese diskussion zu führen um
deutschen wurzeln noch schwieriger
überzeugt beide sachen einfach nur einen
begriff gibt herr frank sie sind jetzt
natürlich kein experte dafür aber wenn
sie jetzt hören dass beispielsweise
schon bei sechs bis achtjährigen es
erleichtert werden soll hormon blogger
zu verschreiben ist es eigentlich
körperverletzung also bei kindern schon
ich habe patienten diesen transsexuell
und das ist nicht an erzogen oder so
sondern das sind menschen die kommen auf
die welt und fühlen sich im falschen
körper und das wird nur zum teil
gelindert auch durch die operation
und diese menschen brauchen toleranz ja
die sind früher gehänselt worden wenn
sie dann frauenkleider tragen dass man
usw
aber das ist ein heißes thema es ist ein
ernstes thema und es ist mir im moment
viel zu marktschreierisch und die gefahr
besteht tatsächlich und bei ihm war das
offensichtlich der fall dass die
beratung nicht gut war oder so nehmen
sie zwar hätte man vielleicht erkannt
dass sie pflicht zu frauen hingezogen
fühlen und eigentlich überhaupt nicht
transsexuellen sind so würde ich jetzt
mal so höre ich das ein bisschen raus
also es war eine fehldiagnose die jetzt
zu einem eingriff geführt hat er nicht
mehr reversibel ist und ich fürchte wenn
man es in der art und weise betreibt wie
es gerade betreibt das viele solche
fehlentwicklungen stattfinden und leute
dann quasi ihr ganzes leben auch zum
teil ruiniert wird also es ist ein sehr
ernstes thema es braucht sehr viel
toleranz aber es sollte reise
stattfinden und es sollte nicht quasi so
sein dass ich leute über dieses thema
politisch gesellschaftlich ja soll ich
sagen profilieren um dann wieder
aufmerksamkeit zu erhaschen nein es ist
ein ernstes thema es gehört in die
sprechstunde und man muss natürlich
sagen
sie haben die ersten
aktivisten die haben sicherlich dafür
gesorgt dass in der gesellschaft eine
viel höhere toleranz da war und sie
wurden teilweise auch durch intoleranz
sind die entscheidung rein getrieben
sonst hätten sie einfach getraut einfach
so zu sagen wie sie sind und wir müssen
das wort toleranz ist sehr sehr wichtig
aber wir müssen das bitte schön leise
aktiv gewesen hier mit gehen ja hier
wirklich mit gehen also erstmal wirklich
respekt fairness jahre lang absolut ich
bin da wirklich beeindruckt wie sie das
auch erzählen und und auch
selbstkritisch und bis zu sehen und und
ich finde was sie gerade gesagt haben
die toleranz in der gesellschaft die
offenheit in der gesellschaft solchen
menschen gegenüber die solche
empfindungen und gefühle haben ich
glaube das wird uns alle voranbringen
und dass man diese dinge das sage ich
jetzt mal als privatperson im privaten
im heimlichen mit sich ausmachen muss
ich glaube das sollte der vergangenheit
angehören und insofern da bin ich einer
meinung mit ihnen herr frank dass das
toleranz in der gesellschaft offenheit
in der diskussion auch die tür ist dass
man dann auch diese
beratungsmöglichkeiten in anspruch
nehmen kann die dringend noten aber die
schwierigkeit dass er gerade immer so
dass zb männer die frauenkleidung tragen
dann heißt das direkt dass es eine
transfer es muss aber gar nicht und das
kann ja genauso sein das ist ein mann
ist der gerne kleidung trägt und da
schließt sich gerade das fenster oder
wenn eine frau halt einfach sehr sehr
groß ist und gerne keine ahnung hat wie
sport macht oder so was in die richtung
dann heißt es immer jetzt schon du bist
ja so burschikos du bist dann geht es ja
man verloren gegangen wie wärs denn je
mehr testosteron und ich denke halte ich
dass dieses fenster derzeit um einiges
kleiner wird darauf
weiß man halt auch die alten aktivisten
hinaus den 70er und 80er jahren weil die
haben nämlich die befürchtung dass sie
selber als kinder und jugendliche heute
tradition ihren würden also wenn sie
heute leben würden und gerade das es
halt auch die schwierigkeit an diesem
selbstbestimmung gesetz das 14 jährige
dann tatsächlich schon können sollen was
dann ihr jeweiliger personen stand ist
was ihr jeweilige vorname sein so sie
finde es viel zu früh genau das heißt er
jetzt immer dass dieses gesetz total
getrennt ist von den medizinischen
maßnahmen wie zum beispiel ich kann halt
von meinen geschichte wiederum reden wo
ich da mir dass das darum besorgt habe
und zwar ohne gutachter und direktheit
bei einem frauenarzt der mir das
verschrieben hat die krankenkasse ist
übernommen danach hat sich bei der
matinee keiner mehr darum gekümmert
ob ich dann überhaupt also ob ich
wirklich dran ständer letztendlich bin
und die gleiche befürchtung habe ich
letztendlich auch bei dieser
namensänderung wenn jemand schon seinen
namen geändert hat dann zeigt das ja
eine gewisse seriosität aber ob
derjenige hat man wirklich trans ist
oder ob der womöglich irgendwie ja zum
beispiel ich habe also ihr
lösungsvorschlag wäre es später zu
machen erst mit 18 vielleicht oder was
ihr vorschlag also auf jeden fall erst
mit 18 das auf jeden fall und dass es
halt nicht zu verfrühten operationen und
so weiter kommt also ich hatte zum
beispiel im krankenhaus nebenwert einen
18-jährigen der hat direkt mastektomie
höchst direktor reaktion wie zusammen
gemacht da sorgt die gebärmutter und
eierstöcke entfernung bei dem sein arzt
ihm gesagt hat dass er sonst krebs
bekommen würde und das war halt keine
weitere irgendwie erklärungen halt
darüber also klar eigen war bewusst dass
er dann keine kinder kriegen kann aber
krebs es halt irgendwie da eine gefahr
bei möglichen zehn jahren habe es ist ja
nicht laden die politik befördert das
mit dem selbstbestimmungsrecht auf jeden
fall ja also da ist der halt sehr
wichtig wenn die bei diesem
selbstbestimmung das gesetz bei den
anhörungen eben wie gesagt auch
kritische stimmen reichen holen also zum
beispiel trans team sorgeberechtigt
fällt mir ein das ist eine vereinigung
da geht es darum dass die kinder gerade
alle tradition ihren und dieses web it
on the display haben das wird der markt
gestritten dass es das gibt das heißt
plötzlich ja eintreten agent uri ab dem
14 lebensjahr ungefähr oder ab dem 13
das heißt diese leute die wissen eben
nicht in der kindheit wie hier mein
nachbar geschildert hat im das sieht
schon trans sind sondern ist es
plötzlich wir haben ungefähr der
pubertät eintreten dass die der meinung
sind dass sie transportfähig das ist
aber als so dass sie entdecken dass ich
schwul oder lesbisch sind und dann
denken sie müssten um in die
gesellschaft zu passen als letzte frage
zu ihrem thema wie geht es ihnen denn
heute also mir geht es jetzt auf jeden
fall wieder besser ich hatte meinen
ganzen bachelor hatte ich als mann
gemacht das kann ich sehr sehr schwierig
vor allem fand ich das schwierig werden
kopiert habe ich dann probiert zwischen
der elektrotechnik und genau das hat sie
nicht so gut geklappt aber jetzt master
hat ich habe direkt als frau angefangen
klar ich habe die ganze zeit die
verwechslungen aber ich das dann richtig
stellt dann würde ich auch immer gut
angenommen also daher ja jetzt fühle ich
mich nicht mehr so als würde ich mich
die ganze zeit verstellen das kann ich
super vielen herzlichen dank dass die
geschichte geteilt ich finde es ganz
wichtig und bleiben sie da auch so
kritisch und laut und nun kommen wir zu
einem etwas anderem thema sie kennen das
ja hier sind weil schnelle themenwechsel
nach acht zu lernen schritte und was
herz mitgebracht hat
ja das thema was ich ihn mitbringen ist
geplante ob soll das klingt wie der
krankheit ist auch eine ja also die
geplante obsolescence was ist damit
gemeint
ich würde heute behaupten 80 prozent der
konsumgüter sind so gebaut dass sie
kürzer halten obwohl sie unter sonst
gleichen bedingungen zu sonst gleichen
kosten mit dreifacher haltbarkeit hätten
gebaut werden können dieses thema
diskutieren wir von unserem verein
brooks nein danke ev jetzt schon seit
2012 als wir damit angefangen haben
wurde gesagt dass es eine
verschwörungstheorie
heute haben wir mittlerweile steht jetzt
auch schon in der eu mit drin also
geplante auktion des sands ist als
problemfeld erkannt allerdings passiert
viel zu wenig und das ist natürlich
etwas wo wir genauso zu packen müssen
wie den anderen bereichen und eine
geplante ob solutions des worts ab so
lässt
sind geplante sollbruchstellen keine
sollbruchstellen sollbruchstellen sind
etwas gutes da würde der ingenieur ja
würde sagten die warte mal eine
sollbruchstelle ist etwas das soll
brechen damit etwas schlimmeres nicht
passieren es sind schwachstellen es sind
aber auch manchmal so dinge wenn sie zum
beispiel sagen mein kühlschrank ist
kaputt und dann rufen sie meinetwegen
bei media markt an und dann sagen die
vielleicht ja das dauert seit sechs
wochen müssen wir einen schicken was man
sagen viele dass bei mir wieder zu hause
ankommt kaufe ich mir doch lieber gleich
nein es ist hat wieder geklappt
eigentlich gleich gesagt wie man denn
nicht über die technik verfügt das gerät
hat nur eine gewisse haltbarkeit damit
extra kaputt geht ja da werden richtig
sogar ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel ein
krebs handmixer dahin hat man auch schon
andere der iss kaputt gegangen haben wir
den ausrüster auseinandergebaut von der
werkstatt da ist den zahnräder drin
grundstoff zahnräder muss kunststoff
sein weil sonst stromschlag
geräuschentwicklung täter war und das
ist ein schneckengetriebe drin das hat
da richtig eine spur eingefräst und im
dritten jahr der nutzung sind die kaputt
gegangen diese zahnräder habe ich nach
langer recherche sogar als ersatzteil
gefunden vier euro 50 hätten sie nur
gekostet aber ohne jede not sind die in
dem handmixer somit metallplatten fest
verbaut gewesen das heißt man kann jetzt
dieses verschleißteil überhaupt nicht
tauschen und das ist eine von vielen
methoden wie dann bei herstellern anders
gemacht wird das eben etwas sozusagen
nach einer bestimmten nutzungsdauer
kaputtgeht essen zähler nachgewiesen
worden den druckern jetzt ist ja gerade
apps und wieder groß in der diskussion
apple ist mittlerweile in italien
verurteilt worden wegen geplanter ob
solist enz in frankreich gibt es gesetze
gegen geplante ob soll distanz also
woanders ist man da schon zu gange ja
nur in deutschland passiert noch zu
wenig frau blank sie ist der
elektrotechnik können sie das bestätigen
sie am definitiv mehr wissen als ich
also es gibt auf jeden fall immer teile
die kaputt gehen können zum beispiel die
ganzen kondensatoren die gehen immer
recht schnell kaputt haben dann kann das
einfach sein das messgerät einmal
aufmachen musste die gingen kondensator
jeweils auslösen dann den neuen
kondensator wieder einlösen also sowas
kann eben auf jeden fall passieren und
ja von lieben brüchigkeit bei plastik ja
kommt natürlich genauso vor haben ist
das halt immer wichtig dass das gerät
gut öffnen kann das tat schrauben gibt
weil wenn man das gerät hat aufbrechen
muss dann das hat natürlich automatisch
schon kaputt ein sehr schöne sehr
schönes beispiel zb die senseo
kaffeemaschine die hat unten drin auch
so eine platine nicht die muss ja
arbeiten und da geht dann auch so ein
kondensator kaputt und dann würde der
elektrotechnik hat sich jetzt sagen
manche wunderbar so ein kondensator
auslösen einen blöden das kriegen wir
auch noch hin das geht auch gleich aber
man muss die maschine kaputt machen sie
ist also verklebt unten das heißt keine
schrauben das heißt man muss sozusagen
die clips wegbrechen aufbrechen damit
man überhaupt dran kommt um es zu
reparieren und ohne jede not haben das
nach kalkuliert mit schrauben das zu
machen wäre genauso teuer wie diese clip
geschichte also es ist jetzt keine
kosten entscheidungen schritte hier ist
habe ich die frage ich habe nachgefragt
wenn ich jetzt unternehmerin wäre für
waschmaschinen da wir schon mal wissen
getestet habe ich wenn ich so
erfolgreich aber sagen wenn man ich wäre
jetzt technisch unternehmerin da würde
ich doch probieren das beste produkt zu
erstellen damit noch die mutter später
tochter sagt die waschmaschine kauft so
aber bei zink ja also warum macht man
eine extra schlechtere produkte die er
dann auch nicht weiter empfohlen werden
die kriegen denn heutzutage in der zeit
des internets schlechte kritiken also
eigentlich ist es doch man weiß sich
doch selber eigentlich in den eigenen
schwanz rein ja tatsächlich nicht
nehmen wir mal ein da hatten wir schon
eine sendung mit mit einem philips
staubsauger 99 euro
und der ist auch kaputt gegangen und der
hat dann innen drin die muss nur richtig
auf flexen den motor und da waren drin
der sauger als ventilator der die
substanz auch mit also so jämmerlich
schlecht gebaut das ist schon sehr
auffällig war okay jetzt fragt man sich
was soll das
naja jetzt ist halt die geschichte nicht
sie kaufen sich ja den staubsauger
sondern sie gehen im laden ihrer wahl
reinsehen dort den staubsauger das heißt
der handel stellt diesen staubsauger
inside regalreihen und ich würde mal
behaupten der handel bestellt geplante
ob solist enz er bestellt das jetzt
nicht in der form dass er sagt macht uns
damals einen schlechten ventilator ein
sondern er bestellte ihnen in der form
dass er sagt leute baut uns bitte
staubsauger die wir alle drei jahre neu
verkaufen können mode wechselt ist ja
auch so was ja wir kennen heute mode
wechsel alle sechs wochen
in der mode der handel wird findet die
pro betrieb sind wir kennen das von
unserer seite her als das time-to-market
problem und da gibt es den wettbewerb
jeder die unternehmen wollen gerne
senden wir mal eine hochpreisige regen
jetzt keine werbung bei waschmaschinen
zum beispiel wird schon ja manchmal von
generation zu generation noch ein
gewisser waschmaschinen hersteller
weitergegeben den kauft man ja weil man
die qualität will aber der macht das
auch mit schwachstellen es geht auch
hoch preise das produkt das interessante
ich gehe zum beispiel es gibt zb von
siemens eine waschmaschine
die unter demselben namen verkauft wird
und dann hatte jemand den kundendienst
menschen zu sich gerufen und gesagt
kommen sie mal ist kaputt machen sie mal
heile und dann hat er ihm das heilige
macht geht leider nicht nach hat er so
im nebensatz gesagt sie müssen sich auch
eine richtige siemens kaufen und da hat
er uns auf etwas aufmerksam gemacht wie
mich es gibt das gleiche modell einmal
als made in romania und einer made in
germany und dann sind das so detail
unterschiede also wie bei zahnrädern zb
die stoßdämpfer diesen unten aufgehängt
mit kunststoff und dann ist manchmal da
wo der stoßdämpfer sozusagen so gegend
zieht metall mit bei damit der druck
nicht aus kunststoff geht und manchmal
ist das metall halt weg und dann geht
der druck immer aus kunststoff drauf und
dann bricht das natürlich irgendwann
solche kleinen unterschiede sind das und
wie kommt das naja war media markt zum
beispiel dann sagt wir brauchen ein
massenprodukt da zahlen wir euch nicht
viel im einkauf man kriegt ja das mit
der konsument kann man wie wachsam
bleiben internet checken kritiken lesen
ja die einfachste methode ist eigentlich
also wenn man jetzt ins regalreihen
greift sind gibt es zwei fragen wenn man
dem verkäufer immer stellen sollte die
erste ist sagen wir mal wie lange hält
das und die zweite frage ist kriege ich
auch in der ganzen zeit ersatzteile und
schon dicke backen das ist auch gut da
haben den richtig praktikabel
lösungsvorschlag wie man als konsument
in der zukunft elektroteilen anderes
kaufte ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend wir sind nächste woche
dienstag wieder für sie da herzlichen
dank an meine gäste tschüss bis bald
[Musik]